Sirens bringing Tokyo to a standstill
[Music]
people urged to take shelter
as North Korea fired a ballistic missile
over Japan without warning it's the
first in five years the country waking
up to a new level of threat
for us here in Japan these kinds of
missile alerts are frightening and
disruptive
the number of missile tests have really
increased in the past week so I think
this is making many countries feel
unsafe not just Japan
it traveled about 2 800 miles before
falling into the Pacific Ocean far
enough to hit the American island of
Guam if it took another trajectory a
deeply unsettling move for Japan
the firing which followed the recent
series of launches by North Korea is a
reckless act and I strongly condemn it
South Korea and the United States
conducted air drills in response to the
launch they insist their recent
large-scale military exercises are
purely defensive
views them as an openly hostile Act
this is the intermediate ballistic
missile experts believe North Korea
Unleashed what could be a far song 12.
Kim Jong-un is on a propaganda push
determined for his enemies to know just
how close he can get
Sky News